these predators are out there they tell
you this
bs story but the reason they do that is
they want you to subscribe to
their newsletter i went into detail
about
exposing that or whatever you will the
last few
views my videos will you don't have to
call out any names but do you believe
right now
there are youtubers in the crypto space
using their audience to basically make
themselves a personal fortune
i believe that there are no crypto
youtubers
who don't do that ladies and gentlemen
welcome to another sunday special today
we're talking about
whatever i want to in this particular
episode we're interviewing a crypto
youtuber
who realized he was manipulating his
audience and you kind of get
walk through his whole life cycle of you
know having this influence realizing
that he's manipulating markets making
money with it feeling bad
i don't know it's just this fascinating
story that most of the time you don't
hear because most people
will never admit it they'll never admit
uh that they're manipulating markets
they'll never admit
that they're doing it for this their own
self-interest but i found this guy and
he's shockingly candid i i think it's an
interview
that it's you know it starts a little
slow but by the end of it you realize
that this is a pretty unique
person um we get the opportunity to hear
from you're not going to hear from a lot
of people like this and when you have a
crypto market like we do right now which
is just bananas
it's important to remember it's
important to remember this stuff and not
get too invested in the hype men
listen there's real things behind crypto
i'm personally invested in bitcoin and
ethereum but the problem is is you have
these hype men these real
the people who believe in it like a
religion and you know i hope this
interview goes
at least a little ways and dissuading
you from buying too much into the hype
and instead
keeps you thinking rationally about this
uh
crazy time we're living in right now
please bear in mind that this interview
was
recorded like four four to six months
ago uh but with that being said
i hope you enjoy i hope you learned
something let me know what you think in
the comments below
welcome to coffeezilla today we are
talking to
asker fulman who ran the channel uh
in it for the money he's a crypto
youtuber or crypto
hype man almost for certain coins and
he's come today to talk to us about how
he had a realization about the kind of
uh thing that was happening with his
channel he had some personal
realizations that led him to eventually
quit making crypto content altogether
now he runs a
self-development podcast which we can
talk about later
but first before before we get into
anything else thank you for coming on
the show
and uh just share the beginning of your
journey when did you get into crypto
right number one thanks for having me
stephen i appreciate it
and um when did i begin so i guess i'd
been
sort of contemplating what type of
youtube channel
i wanted to start um back in
2016. so i'm an actor as well i mean i
actually have an academic background so
i used to think i would be teaching high
school but
um but okay so i found myself on a movie
set what's that academic background in
by the way
uh so uh i have a master's in danish
which is obviously the equivalent of
english of literature
communication that kind of stuff and um
i have another master's in psychology so
oh wow okay right completely wasted
degrees by the way
but um so but but i'm an actor as well
i'm not a trained actor but
i'm doing quite well um
uh okay so i found myself on set of a
movie uh i had a couple days off i
wasn't needed on set for those days so i
i had some free time on my hands and i
was like okay maybe
maybe now is the time to start this
youtube channel
and i've been i guess like six months
prior to this
i had sort of i tried to invest in some
cryptocurrencies which
proved to be impossible back then
because the bank kept blocking
the transfer of funds so
right but i didn't really know anything
about it so i basically created
three crypto videos uh
about one was about a specific coin two
or more like general
advice but but there was i was very
aware that it's absurd that you sort of
do tutorial videos or share your
knowledge with with
with uh um yeah with with people
when you really don't know anything so i
did promise myself okay i'm not gonna
say anything that i don't feel pretty
sure
i'm right about and if people ask me
about something i don't know about i'm
just gonna
not answer or not say that i don't know
anything about it
so so nothing really happened i uploaded
these three videos i think they were
online for a couple months and then all
of a sudden
one of them just took off got like i
don't know 10
20 000 views and my channel took off and
then i realized okay
i'm just going to take this ball and run
with it i'm going to create more content
right now
this is 2016 you said uh this was
i believe this was very late 2016.
yeah okay so crypto still uh
still early i mean not early but
early yeah sure and this period led up
to
i i guess i was just lucky i started
doing videos right when bitcoin sort of
rallied up to the twenty thousand dollar
mark um and and there weren't that many
altcoins around which is the name for
all the other cryptocurrencies as most
of your viewers will probably know
um but but it was it was it was really
easy to just
pick something and then oh look at this
this looks promising uh
and and and then it would blow up
because everything blew up
pretty much so you're you're running
this crypto channel
um obviously there's this gigantic run
from like two thousand dollars in 2017
to the high of almost twenty thousand
dollars
um in late 2017 everything's going well
you're pumping all these coins and at
the time
maybe you were just kind of excited
about it i mean that was that what it
was when did you realize
um because you told me in your email you
pretty quickly realized you were not
only
like just talking about the market you
were manipulating the market
whether or not you intended to right i
mean i mean i remember
well i guess i vaguely remember so i
would i think
my content was probably like 50 general
advice or thoughts on the crypto market
and 50
hyping specific cryptocurrencies
and i and i remember doing a video on
something and then i looked at the chart
and i was like this this is weird it
just struck me as a weird coincidence
that it would
explode uh just as the the number one
your video went live right i could even
sort of like i could
i could look at the analytics in youtube
a couple days later i'm like
the chart of my video is is almost
identical to the chart of the
cryptocurrency right
and and this was something i think i
invested if i remember correctly
invested quote unquote i bought 350
bucks worth of this cryptocurrency
and then it did it 20x and
and i sold it uh and then it just kept
going
what crypto was that i think this was uh
i believe this one is called
shield i actually checked the charts oh
yeah
shield's dead now it sort of is but it
still has a
pretty good market cap i mean i don't
know if it's still being run
or whatever you're right you're not
you're not in the space anymore but it
had a gigantic run
and you basically started it because you
uploaded a video
you you've unlisted all these videos now
but you sent me one of the videos
because i wanted to get an idea of the
sort of the content you made did i send
you the shield one
yeah yeah you sent me the shield one and
i was looking at the chart of shield
you upload it on december 17th or
whatever
that exact day shield just
spikes into the sky uh
and in fact you talked about two other
cryptocurrencies
and those also had similar movements
based on
you know kind of what you said about
them i think one of them you did not
recommend so it didn't move and the
other one you also recommended
and again right on december 17th
the the market cap went from i think it
was like 4 million to 35 million
in two days and then i think it peaked a
little later
at 110 million or something yeah
right but it was like not like not a
long time later like a short time
later this is a short-term pump that
basically directly
led from your video you can like see the
time
and let me repeat that again four
million dollars
to 35 million dollars or the all-time
high of a hundred and ten million
dollars
think of how insane that is ask her you
ran a channel
of i think at the peak it was like 40 to
50 000 subscribers on that channel
a little more but yeah sure none of us
were very educated back then and i think
it's my impression that a lot of people
would just things have really changed
now
they have they they i mean i mean to
some extent to some extent they have the
general
knowledge level in this space is
definitely bigger than it used to be
but but it was it was bizarre so what
was your question again how
how did how did it happen how can it
happen
yeah well i i guess i guess that must
have been a huge moment where you go a
wow this channel has way more influence
than i thought it did and
b does it occur to you oh i can
use this and make a ton of money from
being able to basically move the market
with whatever
you know kind of garbage coin i want
right okay so so okay so there's a
couple
things to unpack there one so one of
them is
initially i didn't really
believe that i was creating these market
movements
because you know i'm again i have an
academic background i know correlation
doesn't it doesn't necessarily
equal a causal relation i know but every
crypto you talked about on that day
just goes whoop just right no i know
it's it's completely insane right
and and i guess at some point i don't
remember
exactly if this was with the shield
thing or
snavio which is another one i i talked
about uh but at some point i
it it changed from being just a
suspicion to something i was okay
this is me doing this i remember i met
up with a guy
also a fellow crypto enthusiast um
we went we invited me out for a beer i
guess and we went to a bar and had a few
blues and i told him about this theory i
had he was oh for sure man
happens all the time i was like what
does it
and okay so that's when i realized okay
i can probably make a lot of money on
this and um
yeah so but so i i do want to interject
just one thing you i think you
you use the term i recommended the coin
so i've been very careful the whole way
through this
circus to never recommend anything i
don't think i've used that wording
ever i'm just saying oh sure this is i'm
i'm i know
i'm aware that's essentially that's how
people perceive it and people would
write me emails
oh what was your recommendation again
everyone would perceive it as a
recommendation and i was well aware of
that
but i'm just saying i i tried to sort of
frame it as
this is what i just did i just bought
this coin
i think it's a good investment what you
do is up to you
of course it's bs of course it's bs i
mean
but right it is a recommendation without
being a recommendation
it's like all the finance guys on
youtube i'm
all they do all day is tell people how
to invest whatever give people
investment advice
and then at the end or in the
description fold they go oh
none of this is this is all
entertainment it's all just
education entertainment this is not
investment id
advice and of course the truth is is
that they
do that to kind of cover themselves
legally um
so to be fair to you and to make sure
you don't get in a lawsuit sure you
didn't recommend any of it but
you know um it and i'm sure you didn't
want to recommend it but
everybody knew that that's kind of what
it amounted to or at least that's
ostensibly why you were getting the
audience you were because some of these
videos
have like a quarter of a million views
and the crypto
you know enthusiast space is not massive
i mean it's a
it's a small dedicated community so you
are getting
pretty huge numbers um and it's because
people look to you as an
a credible source so
how much money did you make not you
don't have to be specific
look just just give me the ballpark
let's ballpark this
okay so but we should so but we should
before i say that
uh we should get into like the actual
income streams i have or had just
running that channel because now you're
asking this question i think
people expect to hear how much did i
make on crypto investments right
um so okay but i can say this i managed
to
to 65x my initial investment
but my initial investment was very small
it's pretty good
that is pretty good feel pretty good but
i feel pretty confident saying i made
probably around the same amount or or as
much money on
sponsorships on the channel sponsored
content
and i also opened a cryptocurrency
newsletter thing i think i published it
for
four or five months for free and after
that i said
now it's going to be 99 bucks a month
and a lot of people signed up for that
oh so you did like a paid subscriptions
that's a lot of money
just for a newsletter but it was uh it
was there
there would always be at least one
crypto tip and the track record was just
not a recommendation guys a tip did i
say
this is this is another misstep i never
used that word either
but but i mean i would feature at least
one
cryptocurrency that i thought was an
interesting investment
and this all went and and honestly
stephen i was like
i didn't give the moral aspects
of this too many considerations during
the first
let's call it six to nine months
honeymoon too because you're making
money your channel's making money
people love your content people are
happy you're publishing it there's
you know especially when things are
going up
nobody's gonna criticize no one's upset
nobody's unhappy with you
right in fact you could almost pick any
stock or sorry any coin
in uh in 2017 and chances were that
it kind of was doing okay um of course
then 2018 hits
and is that when you first had your
first wake up the big dip
in 2018 that maybe people are getting
hurt on the other end of this or is that
a possibility
yeah i mean that that was one big [ __ ]
show when
when bitcoin started tanking it dragged
everything else down the whole market
cap of the entire crypto market went
from
roughly a billion down to 150 million
something like that it was
really really bad or am i and that's
people's life savings or
whatever they invested disappearing
almost overnight i mean uh you know
obviously some people got out
better than others sure but some people
lost a ton of money
right i mean i mean the worst part was i
was one of those people
uh ironically because i would
place myself in a situation where so i
would publish this
newsletter and my featured coin
and i would be honest or honest
semi-open
honest whatever uh about this i mean
obviously i've invested in this
and you can sort of frame that as oh i
put my money where my mouth is you know
but i mean is it normally that's a good
thing um
many people stress that as a good thing
i think it is in other
aspects of life but but here is a little
sort of
hypocrisy a little bit of a conflict of
interest a little bit
sure but but at least isn't it it's just
still better to
to know that okay this guy has a
conflict of interest than
me pretending not to or okay but
here's what would happen okay so i would
invest in something uh
i would actually typically accumulate
very slowly over time
before i published my report because i
didn't want to manipulate the market
in anticipation of the report coming out
but but then i would sit on
sometimes pretty uh absurd quantities of
of a specific cryptocurrency and then it
would go up and then
when my report was published it was
immediately spike and then i would later
do a video on it which would cause
another spike
typically but then i realized okay this
is kind of unethical because these
people are paying me good money
each month to get this recommendation so
non-recommendation so so i would just
huddle as we call it holding in crypto
space
to my own detriment but i was like yeah
oh you'd hold on during the pump
and then after it dumps like you just
hold on to it
this is after i've had all these
thoughts about morality and ethics and
stuff
wait wait we're getting ahead of
ourselves when did you have that first
thought about like
maybe maybe there's something there's an
ethical question here that i should pay
attention to
maybe some people are losing out what
was that thought i mean
it sort of went hand-in-hand with the
number of
emails i got from people telling me i
was a scammer
they wanted to kill me they hated me
they lost everything because
i had a couple death threats because
people lost so much money
i assume yeah i mean uh one guy wrote me
he he'd opened three new credit cards
maxed out all of them
just to go all in on one specific
cryptocurrency i mean
i mean that's i i actually i mean even
though i felt
some responsibility that sort of
that's the when i got that email i was
like i don't i actually don't feel
responsible for this this is
so reckless this behavior is so reckless
i mean i would never
encourage or that type of behavior or
sure sure sure sure sure but it it
success
it's excessive of course but at the same
time you're thinking to yourself
yikes that was my recommendation not
recommendation
uh that that led to this okay so then
that's when you had the idea
well like maybe you can't sleep at night
too well
if um if you're actively like profiting
off the pump side
of your thing so you decide to huddle
the
the coin and even if it dips just out of
a principle of i recommended it so
if i own it i'm owning it for some sort
of long
um view so so just to i'm not trying to
make myself sound as a saint here i
there was a period of yeah i don't know
exactly how long
two three four months something like
that before i started
implementing this ethical practice if
you will
um oh two three four months of of riding
the pump
something like that i'm i mean maybe not
how profitable was that for you
in terms of maybe like this were you
able to double your money were you able
to triple your money what
what were you no i was that's that's the
period where i was able to 64x my money
but but
but as i said it was a pretty measly
amount of money i sure sure
i mean had i had 20 grand to go without
i mean we would have been speaking
right yeah so it was more like this
bizarre thing where i had a few hundred
dollars that and then
i was like what what that now this is
four grand although it was just a few
hundred dollars a minute ago right
and then it sort of happened again and
then like okay i actually have some
some you're a terrible pump and dump
artist i got to tell you you have too
many morals for it
you don't have enough money for it right
you're not very good at this i've got to
tell you i've i've talked to a lot of
people who've
run scams intentionally or not obviously
in your case it was different but um
and they typically you need that kind of
sociopathic element to it where you just
don't care
if people get hurt and you don't have
that so you you
you started feeling bad then you start
hodling and
what happens there are you still making
money i would guess not so i'm making
so under during the what what is
commonly referred to as the crypto
winter
now um so after the crash um
of bitcoin essentially and the whole
market
i mean i would make money on the
newsletter
but obviously my numbers there would
dwindle as well
and i wouldn't make money on any of the
investments
or or a featured investment or whatever
that would be all
losses and the amount of hate mail i got
was
increasing day by day and um
it just started feeling like one big
[ __ ] show and the
the only the only viable income stream
during this period um during this almost
two year period i might add
was really these people reaching out um
companies launching new cryptocurrencies
or running icos
uh which is equivalent of an ipo explain
what that is for people who don't know a
initial coin offering initial coin
offering well it's essentially just a
funding round i guess a public funding
round
and they i didn't jump on on that wave
initially but
there was like a good couple few months
where every everybody would just make
insane profits on every single ico
then the american authorities started
sort of
looking into it and shutting it down
essentially
but there would still be weird other
icos in europe it would still be illegal
and there were other countries were
running them and
and we should be clear a lot of these
icos their coin was based on nothing i
mean they like basically
copy paste of the ethereum source code
essentially
yeah yeah yeah okay and they were
basically pumping it up as the next big
thing tons of people were getting in
the coin would subsequently go to near
or almost
zero or sometimes zero and then everyone
would lose their money except the
founders of the ico and the marketers uh
who both kind of cash out whether it be
through sponsorship money or through
um you know the ico money
um so you got approached by these guys
and they're basically saying hey
it's [ __ ] it's crypto winner don't you
want a few a few bucks how much
were they willing to pay so that changed
a lot
actually so i think the first time it
happened
a company offered me 500 bucks just to
do
like a not even a tutorial just like
point attention to their um idea uh
which was an a
a legitimate idea launched by
professional or business professionals
who had
been running other companies for decades
so i felt pretty
confident about doing that and i was
like whoa 500 bucks for a video
the next time around it was a thousand
bucks for a video
then i mean it really depends on your
numbers
what they want whether they pay you in
their
native currency or in u.s dollars which
was also sometimes the case or
bitcoin or ethereum but
anything from 500 bucks to 10 000 bucks
i have a for one video that it takes you
what how many
a day i mean when people pay me 10 grand
to make a video i just do spend at least
two days
researching the whole thing and i mean
so yeah i probably spent
two three days on that but here's what i
want to think because i don't want
people to think that um
you know you were a sellout or anything
like else i think this is indicative of
the crypto market as a whole
and what the crypto market is still
doing you got you subsequently
got out because you were a little bit
disgusted with the whole thing
the uh the mentality of crypto investing
which
seems to be you know just pump up
the next ice the next coin pump up the
next coin pump this coin that coin the
other coin
um and these people basically profit a
ton of money
from riding the pump before they
actually you know release the video
whatever they know the stock's going to
go or the coin's going to go up
uh and you're kind of discussing with it
so i want people to be clear when we're
talking about these
you know sponsorships when we're talking
about these pumps
this still happens and as an investor
you should know that if you're gonna get
into crypto
not very regulated um you have to
know these risks are there and the
people that you tr you
trust on youtube may or may not be
disclosing
where their interests lie what coins
they're holding
when they're selling so i wanted to make
a quick copy out there because i
i should have brought it up earlier
that's why i want to have you on
you quit crypto you're out your story is
kind of like
your your story has moved on from crypto
now you're doing other things
but this is still going on is that why
you [ __ ] felt compelled to come on the
show
i i think the main reason i wanted to
come on this show really is it
i guess it sort of left me with with a
trauma
almost uh which which is a part of the
story we haven't really gotten into
yet but i was obviously as a youtuber
or as a social media uh personality and
you could probably relate to this
obviously you peak a little bit to your
competition just to see
what are they doing are they growing
their channel can i learn something from
this guy or
whatever sure so so i would i would do
that too
and uh oh man i lost my train of thought
here but
but it oh yeah okay so i regained it
again so
the main thing is there's this narrative
especially in the cryptocurrency space
it's sort of like this
a narco capitalist
mindset in a sense that the banks are
evil
they're out to get us um
decentralized finance can solve that
riddle that's at least that's the
narrative we're running with right here
decentralized finance and there's some
truth to that obviously
there is some truth to that i mean look
just looking back at 2008 and the whole
bailout of the banks and
i mean there's there's a lot of stuff to
criticize there rightfully so
but i just realized okay 95
of the audience my audience on social
media
want to hear this mantra they want to
they want me essentially to be a general
we're in this battle right and and they
want me to say climb the damn hillside
death to the banksters and all that
stuff right
and i and and i was really tempted to go
down that route but
i mean i'm i'm quite interested in
philosophy and talking about
producing the arguments for and against
some thesis antithesis etc
all that stuff so so it was pretty clear
to me that
no no this is a little oversimplified i
can't actually sign on to this
thing i'm not drinking that kool-aid and
i was and i was trying to explain my
audience
listen guys these predators
are out there they tell you this bs
story
it's not necessarily an untrue story
partially maybe but the reason they do
that is they want you to subscribe to
their newsletter and invest in these
things they're just pandering to you
and they know what you believe they
pander to you they reflect your beliefs
back to you
cynically because they don't actually
care they just want to just kind of push
your buttons you're saying
right and people didn't know that you
said i want to pull back the curtains
how did people respond to that
the more i went into detail about
exposing that or whatever you will um
the less views views my videos will get
bro people don't want to hear about the
the the
the bearish views they don't want to
hear about
anything that goes against the hype
train
right i mean i even want to want to go
as far as to say the truth
you can't handle the truth right i mean
people people don't want to
they just don't want to hear it and and
i think even though some people
i mean that's so sad though in a way you
develop this audience only to realize
you're a slave to what your audience
wants
yeah not actually not the other way
around not the other way around
the audience doesn't care what you have
to say that you're almost a puppet for
reinforcing what they already believe
about
crypto and handing them like pics to
that may or may not be legitimate all to
justify their pre-existing
beliefs and they could be getting
scammed or saying in some cases maybe
they are being scammed and they have no
idea
and they don't want to hear it that they
are being scammed they might want to
roll it right and i want to i want to
elaborate on on what you just said there
because i think
this is this is crucial right one thing
is being scammed
in you know in such a way that you have
described here on your channel uh in
many of your videos right
there is like a specific scam a course
you sign up for
then there's an up sale so that's a scam
right but there's a bigger scam
going on which is you being presented
with directly targeted social media
content every single day
and this is again this is so obvious
right in this day and age right the
algorithms target
you they they don't just do blanket or
canvas
oh let's try and send out these videos
to these random people no
no no they know what's going to keep you
glued
to the screen right and they'll give you
more of that
and it's just so bizarre as a content
creator
to realize that in real time as it
happens that
okay i can keep growing this channel i
can wait make way more money
i'm sort of going bankrupt right now
because i because i
keep diverging from this narrative
people want to hear but i can't bring
myself
to i just can't bring myself to lie
essentially yeah even though they want
to be lied to in a way the crypto
community
is almost i mean i i don't want to lump
people together
the people who followed a narrative of
like
don't tell me anything just give me the
tips give me the hot tips whatever
those people were complicit in their own
deception
and you couldn't bring yourself even
though they kind of wanted it
they you can bring yourself to do it but
then
that's one aspect and then there's
another aspect of people watching a
video such as this one we're
recording right now and they probably
know oh yeah okay these guys are on to
something
they know what we're talking about but
still
in terms of their investments they need
to protect their investment right
so it's not in their best interests
financially
to spread this message that hey all this
anarcho-capitalism
these people many of these people don't
really mean it they just say it because
it's a nice sounding narrative
they know 99 of their audience subscribe
to those ideas and
that's how they can keep growing and
building a tribe
right that's another thing right the the
tribe from a marketing
plan yeah i'm more worried i don't
really care about the
ideology like you said it's a tool i
mean
what you're describing is grifting which
has been around forever someone just
cynically using an
ideology to convince people to basically
take their money
um so i'm not so concerned about the
anarcho-capital
or whatever whatever you believe i don't
really care the point is
is that youtubers giving advice
or sorry they probably would say we're
not giving recommendations right
nobody's giving recommendations
uh these people have ulterior motives
sometimes
especially when money gets involved when
the opportunity
to make serious like 65x returns like
you said
your priorities change right you don't
have to call out any names but do you
believe right now
there are youtubers in the crypto space
using their audience to basically make
themselves a personal fortune
i believe that there are no
crypto youtubers who don't do that
so i i know that's a radical statement
but but but
but no okay so we you and i had i think
we had a brief discussion about this on
on your screening call with me i guess i
mean there are a few people
that i i watch their videos every now
and then i mean i'm not very interested
in the space anymore
but where i'm like one guy for i can i
can even mention him um
crypto daily uh cameron is his real name
i've met him once um
very nice guy uh he's a friend of a
friend what he does
he sort of puts a comedic angle on the
whole thing so it's
just like watching a comedy show and as
you watch this comedy show
you get the daily crypto news and he
always discloses
when his content is sponsored i would
think
that's as close to ethical as you can as
you can be
in the cryptocurrency space i mean there
are other people
who will do the same thing but but but
let me just
put it this way there's there's no way
you can run a cryptocurrency channel
full time
without without playing in
to this these narratives that we talked
about pandering uh
uh and or
and you also need to make money from
somewhere and the thing i see
most common is okay so i know i still
get emails from some companies
i'm still on their list i guess so uh uh
well
two thousand dollars to to give us a
mention about this
and then i see all the cryptocurrency
youtubers give give them a mention so i
know why they do that at that point in
time
but they don't say anything about it
being sponsored content oh no they don't
you know john mcafee right now is
indicted by the us for doing exactly
that he was the very last guy i
interviewed on um
on my channel really yeah i know it's
it's very sad because uh
well it depends if you're a fan of john
mcafee or not i
i kind of am he's kind of this i mean
he's an intriguing
but anyway it doesn't matter what you
think about it the point is he had just
he had
pumped all these crypto coins and never
disclosed that hey i'm being
paid a lot of money um to do this and so
right now he's indicted for
that exact reason i think he's sitting
in jail somewhere
so so i mean this stuff is really
serious but it's just happening
on such a wide scale across you know
multiple multiple multiple youtubers
but like everybody everybody like i feel
like everybody's been caught doing this
there's a bunch of rappers now who've
been caught
pumping icos there's like it's hit the
mainstream
everybody's pumping some garbage altcoin
just to make it make a quick buck
because these companies are willing to
pay you so much money to do it
but one thing but again again i want to
sort of stress or
i feel like there's a silver lining
somewhere right where
one thing is okay so they pump some coin
right
but another thing is the whole thing
that led up to that moment
that made them that even made that
possible right so you've been following
some person whether it be john mcafee
or some rapper or a crypto guru whatever
you've been following them for a while
and you've been watching their videos
and for each video you consume
they build a little bit trust more trust
all the time right so they add to the
personal you you're sort of building a
personal relationship to people
you feel like you know them but they
don't know you but you feel like you
know them right
then comes to kill right or the kill or
the cell or whatever it is
but it's just this whole bs
the more square and simple the general
messages are
the more red flags are in it to me i
mean
oh like a simple message being this this
coin is going to the moon guys everyone
jump in
yeah or maybe rather these people are
evil right
we're the gold like in the world finance
like in the world finance banking system
these people are evil they've been
holding us down
now is our time to rise up
this is a revolution guys right you want
to join it or you just want to
sit here and be nice but passive good
sheeple
right but i love this i feel like a lot
of crypto is just
at this point maybe just driven by fomo
i mean it's not even like
any kind of philosophy maybe the like
early adopters were
like maybe philosophically interested
now
it's happening because people are just
afraid of missing out on
you know giant wealth opportunities sure
who's been in the space how do you
how do you judge an actual crypto
opportunity
versus just hype i mean would you say
that
i always you know think about like uh
bitcoin and ethereum is
sort of the safest bets would you kind
of agree to that or
what do you think that depends on
the market i mean it depends on the
overall trend and
um good this is good a nuanced take
good right okay that was easy
but no uh okay so what's your question
again
specifically so for pete so for people
out there
uh who are looking at crypto they go
maybe this is a good opportunity
maybe not i don't know where to begin
but i don't want to get like basically
persuaded by some essentially
charlatan to jump into some unsavory
investment
how would you how do you think about
crypto now now that you've distanced
yourself from it
okay so there's a there's a couple
things there
first of all you're right it's pretty
much
all hype in some sense it's all
psychology
really but then comes to realization
following that but that's actually also
the case
for the stock markets for all of money
yeah
it actually is it's just on a much
bigger scale and of course because
crypto is such a small scale it's much
easier to manipulate right
i mean and that's still the case but i
mean it's growing all the time
so so and then and then ironically
you use the word charlatan i think
that's that's very uh
that's probably the right word to use in
many cases in in the crypto space
but ironically it's really about finding
something
before the charlatans find it and start
talking about it
that's that's the i mean i'm i'm
involved i'm i'm
i'm in a single telegram group i'm
involved in a single
cryptocurrency project sort of on the
sidelines i don't really spend any time
on it i don't talk about it on social
media but i talk about with with some
friends online
um ants i mean some some some of those
people are really good they do they dig
really deep and it's but but at the end
of the day it's really about
if you can anticipate okay how
how is this likely to be presented is is
and of course if they have
advisors like high profile silicon
valley if they have peter thielon
or or mark zuckerberg's sister was on
a company's board that reached out to me
a couple years back i mean i mean stuff
like that
it's really okay so you know they have
some really good connections and you can
look at the chart
has it moved yet no it has not but again
all this i don't really believe that
this oh this is this is for the long
term you know this is
uh just buy this crypto keep it for for
for
five ten years you'll be good no [ __ ] no
i mean
get the hell out as soon as possible i
mean you can still make
you there there are still some good
financial opportunities in this space
but you have to ask yourself this
question and this goes for the the
regular fiat and stock money markets as
well
stock and money markets as well and
commodity market for all markets
really is most people lose money so so
you have to explain to me
in a credible manner and yourself
essentially is there any good reason why
you
you belong to the group it's not going
to lose money here
i mean i i i have a friend who has most
people are biased to say yes because
they
people typically overestimate their own
intelligence
uh and expertise and a skill especially
when they're first getting in
and this is sort of the problem with
crypto is nearly
um was changing now but nearly everyone
in crypto are
unsophisticated investors who maybe all
they know how to do is read a chart and
that's it
right and and add to that that the
crypto markets are so
unpredictable that that your first
experience as a completely naive actor
in this space
might be a good one right because you're
so naive you have no idea what you're
doing you're just following
the crowd oh we're going this way oh
let's go this way right so you buy in
some [ __ ] coin and and then you 5x your
money and then you sell it
and you're like this was that was easy
let's do it again right
so so so that that's even worse because
that triggers a
conditioned response bad learning
environment yeah it's a terrible
learning environment
to put it mildly but
you you quit crypto i mean i think we've
alluded to this several times in this
story but uh you have a video called i'm
quitting crypto
you know all this stuff and i was
looking in the comments and everyone
seems to think oh it's just because he
lost money or oh you just weren't you
didn't just didn't
do that he'll be about whatever can you
explain to people the real reason you
left crypto if if you you know if you
could summarize it in a few minutes
we've already heard about how
how jaded you were kind of realizing
what your audience wanted versus what
the truth was
as you saw it and your inability to
speak
that truth in fa like or risk losing all
your subscribers
um what what was it so i found myself at
a
crossroad and i and i i had
during the couple years i ran this
channel i i realized okay
i know exactly actually how i can make
a lot of money on this i i at one point
i even have like a you have a formula
you have a total formula the whole
formula and not just with youtube right
not just with sponsorships
but i could build out this newsletter i
could do like a sister newsletter
that sort of appealed to another
demographic all this was on the table
right i met up with people i had
six employees over the years i think in
various
positions i mean uh and i would
and i just but i just could not
it's sort of like this yeah it was like
i was presented with this choice
ultimately i tried to not make the
choice to to find some
golden middle path right but i just
ultimately had to realize that is not
possible
i can i could choose the money and i can
probably become a multi-millionaire
in a very short period of time or
i can choose something else but it but
but it was what is that something else
i mean there's something else could be
anything uh it's but in some ways it's
your
ethics right oh sure of course it is i
mean i mean i try to tell myself oh
now i'm sort of following my passion
which is something i usually
make a little fun of or in a gentle
manner at least
when peop when people say that but but i
actually am
only pursuing things that i'm super
passionate about right now
but but the whole financial thing is
right because i
i hadn't had a job for a good three
years i think
i i didn't need a job i mean this whole
circus covered all my
life expenses um
so just this whole okay i'm gonna stop
doing this
people are gonna stop reaching out to me
with offers all the time
i'm gonna go from from
being sort of i'm not a minor celebrity
that's obviously not what you are when
you're doing social media but
people would stop me in the street every
now and then oh you're that money guy oh
yeah i'm the money guy you know
and all this stuff i would just have to
let go of all that
but especially the financial
independence thing
and also because i did and i do want to
stress this i do have i do have
a few people who still who i'm still in
touch with who followed me on the
original in and for the money channel
that are smart
and who are ethical and yeah and and who
took this to heart
and have you even pushed back on some of
the stuff i said and taught
me stuff so there are good people out
there but it's
i want to say less than one percent and
and
and it's really something this is
actually something that every person
going back to the whole crossroad i
found myself at
you have to decide with yourself are you
willing to do
what it takes really essentially
sacrificing
what is hopefully some of your moral
principles
or do you think you're able to find some
ethical manner to balance these things
you made an extremely hard choice
i mean i we say it on the channel that
people should
make the ethical choice but we also know
that a lot of people don't and the
reason
a lot of people don't is because you
know money's tempting
fame's tempting adulation the
you know you're getting tons of emails
saying oh i love your channel whatever
you kind of gave that up um invites
for we fly you out to the screen yes
yeah every everything you just gave it
up because you realized there was no way
you could
ethically exist in the crypto space
that's what
it's what essentially you just told me
right um
what are you doing now that's a
question that's very easy to ask a
little hard to answer so i
so i'm originally danish so i'm
bilingual and occasionally i work with
translation companies uh just finished a
project they're
sort of between gigs right now but i do
acting too
objectively going surprisingly well and
i'm moving into screenwriting
potentially production to movie
production so you are chasing the
passion even though you
say you kind of joke about it but yeah
you're you are pursuing your passion
actually
oh i i absolutely am i mean but it's
it's just one of those things where
there are so many variables that
you you can't control all of them so you
might to some extent you're at
the mercy of other people gatekeepers
and stuff
so i feel like i feel like your story is
one of kind of being
i don't know it's uh the proverbial deal
with the devil you know like
money status fame whatever
right and um you know you turned it down
you said you found philosophy what is it
what does that mean to you
i mean so i mean i could i just say this
because
i have a video on my channel called uh
confessions of a copywriter
where i think i've seen it the guy said
the exact same thing he goes you know i
found philosophy and i realized maybe
making money
wasn't you know everything what but what
does that mean to you
so so i mean so i mean i've i've read
philosophy books when i was 15. so
this is back in the mid 90s so i mean
i've always been interested in
philosophy
but i think maybe i should have said
epistemology i
um there's there's a i'm going to make a
recommendation here there's a great
youtube channel out there called street
epistemology
by a guy called anthony mac mcbosco this
this is shout out to someone who really
deserves it if you have
you haven't seen it i take it but it's
not just
it it's it's hilarious he uses socratic
questioning method to to interview
people in the street he's in texas
so a lot of them are quite religious and
then he just
asks him it's really just about why do
you believe
what you believe that is that is more or
less how do you know that you know yeah
that's what it is technology is right or
no no that's why i say believe because
knowledge is a little
iffy uh but that is really just this
whole
questioning your own mind that was sort
of the basis for my podcast too i tell
this story where
this is here many many years ago
whatever i would live with my girlfriend
back then
one day i found this photo and she was
standing there with a guy
they were like holding each other and i
was like who the [ __ ] is this guy
like i could just tell there was some
chemistry between these people right
and then i was like who the [ __ ] is this
guy and she looks at me looks at me
as if i'm in a [ __ ] right and she goes
have you lost it dude
that's you and i look again i'm like oh
that's right that's right
it's me right but that's when i realized
you can't even trust your senses right
and and people think oh that's just him
maybe he was having a psychotic
breakdown or whatever no
no dude that's everyone there's really
just this whole that oh just because i
see it with my own eyes that that means
it's 100 true there's no
if i remember something it must be
correct i mean
our standard mo as human beings
is simply not has very little to do with
reality with any external reality
whether you believe in it
or not i guess i'm just a random sorry
about that no no no no it's okay no it's
okay i think it's a good
uh pitch for those who are interested in
metaquest
that's the podcast that you run i think
it gives people a good kind of
it's a feeling for what you do right but
that i've stopped running
actually so i don't know send people
over there
you know what if people want to follow
me they can go to ask ask her
that's a youtube channel very small 100
subscribers
that's probably the only one that's
going to be that's your work
you're working with right now right um
could we just get that point across that
i tried to rebrand
the youtube channel the in it for the
money youtube channel oh yeah yeah yeah
let's let's look
yeah right you you told me this you told
me this and then
um one thing that's immediately apparent
when you go to your channel which has
been
uh rebranded from the crypto world and
you were uploading to it
is that as soon as you stopped talking
about
as soon as you stopped being in it for
the money which can we talk about how
ironic that name is
you actually were not of all the people
your your uh title of your show is
totally deceptive because you are not
clearly in it for the money and when you
stop being in it when i started the
channel
right when you stopped being in it for
the money though uh
the the subscribers the views everything
dried up like
super quick you went from having a
channel that was getting like 250k
views of video to now it's it's much
less than that
yeah lucky to get a thousand views now
yeah
so literally everyone just follows
and once you started challenging once
you started challenge challenging them
with uh
you know maybe this isn't all what you
it's cracked up to be
you lose it all do you think crypto's
still a good investment
that's that that's like saying do you
think stocks are a good investment i
mean there's a very broad question right
sure no no i no i mean i mean uh
are there good the long-term the
long-term crypto outlook like not
as maybe a particular coin but i'm
talking more the technology
the underlying uh kind of
i mean sure i mean i i i'm not a bitcoin
maximalist
some people are i do think it's going to
be around for a very long time but i
mean it's
still the protocol has been compromised
twice so
uh and and it is true what critics
what's his name roubini uh
uh say that it's not backed by anything
i'm just coming with all the classical
arguments here
i think it's going to be around for a
very long time and i i mean blockchain
technology is clearly useful
as many many use cases but when people
say
this is much bigger than the internet i
i
i
anymore right because that's just yeah
because what is this technology without
the internet
it's worthless essentially or at least
some kind of
yeah and right right yeah i think that's
uh clearly hyperbole
so yes optimistic i mean there's and
there's still
there is still is money to be made do
you hold you hold crypto i guess
yeah a little bit i mean i could
actually give a shout out to a
a decentralized crypto player i don't
know if you might
keep me giving a shout out let's not
let's let's stay away from
shout outs related to this just because
uh just just do this okay but i can just
describe what it is i am
using a social media platform that is
sort of
integrated oh okay okay with
cryptocurrency okay that's the only
thing i'm
really involved in right now oscar i've
got to ask you know you've been
in the crypto space uh really during the
good times or in the bad times
can you go through some horror stories
you know
of what what happened in crypto the
things that would happen because
obviously they're people making 65x
and there's also a lot worse than that
can you walk me through some of your uh
i'm sure you've got some battle scars i
do have a lot of battle scars
but okay let's let's start with the
small and move up to the big so
one email that hit me was a guy from
uh he was from south america venezuela i
think a young guy
22 he sent me a photo of himself in his
he was in the navy
actually on a ship in a nice white
uniform he sent you a photo of himself
like to
prove that this is me this is actually
me right yeah and he
sent me along it wasn't a sob email at
all it was sort of like a
it was actually kind of like a thank you
email and he wrote me
i get 286 dollars a month or something
like that two
around three hundred dollars a month
that's my salary down here
and i'm happy to spend 99 bucks on your
newsletter each month
and this was right after the market had
started crashing
i remember that that hit me
that that kind of hurt you know wow
and i i don't remember i think i sent
him an answer back but i don't actually
remember what i wrote okay so that's
like uh
brought a little i was welling up a
little bit reading that email right then
on the other end of the spectrum
i did a sponsored video
and let's just keep it brought um
obviously i
i was obvious to anyone it was a
sponsored video i stated in the video
this is sponsored video the company paid
me this amount but
not this specific amount obviously but
the thing is so they paid me a little
bit upfront
then came the time for me to get the
rest of the payment
and the company completely ignored me
we had we even signed an nda
and a contract this was a us-based
company
but it took me about a year to get that
money
and it was just people lying to me at
the at the executive level
in these companies but the problem is
so many people so not with this but this
has happened multiple times that the ceo
of a company sits so they have
you know maybe they have like a monthly
ama or something like that right
and there was a couple cases where they
they just sat there
lying about me telling straight up lies
about me
oh we never said that one guy said but i
recorded it
and then i shot him an email saying why
do you say that that that
that you never said that you told me i'm
like no no no i didn't and then i sent
him the recording of him saying it
but the thing is i wanted to expose
these guys but here's the thing stephen
so what things were they lying about
there's um
okay like right so there was there was
like good looking
no no this was sort of like some some
specific questions
about their company that would be very
important in
evaluating whether this is a sound
business or not
sure so i had told my subscribers my
19 000 man strong email list
i'm gonna ask this person this question
because i've been in touch with the
company already
and then and then he started someone
asked him on the of a live stream said
oh the enemy for the money guy said
said that he was gonna ask you this
question why haven't you answered it and
then he said oh he never asked me this
question
he's lying he he actually literally said
i was lying and i don't like questions i
don't like that in it for the money
do you do you remember what the question
was like what what it pertained to give
us an idea
it doesn't have to relate to the
question i don't know i mean it could
have been something about a timeline
are you still uh are you still
projecting
are you going to launch this product in
q1 of 2019 or something like that
right and he goes no no no that in it
for the money guy he's an idiot yeah
i don't like that guy
but but here's the thing i wanted to
expose that guy
so bad right and i and i have i
have been recording and i have this
email i have all the materials in the
world
for me to do so but a lot of my the
people who followed me and trusted me
invested in this cryptocurrency so if i
expose this guy
um i mean you're hurting your
subscribers
right and and i chose not to do that and
there's a couple
other examples of very similar
situations where i'm like
man i really want to expose these
[ __ ]
it doesn't and at the end of the day it
doesn't even have to mean
that the company will do worse it could
actually mean that it'll do better
if if it's led by some ruthless
cutthroat ceo right
but who am i to know right but if i have
a thousand people who have trusted me
followed me for years
some of these people i'm actually
friendly with you know
and they went in because of your
recommendation and you expose it and the
stock
gets cr crushed for you know for
for a month they're gonna be pissed or
they maxed out a credit card and they're
gonna lose everything right no
there were people actually maxing out
credit cards for crypto that seemed so
hard to believe
i think at one point that was just the
norm rather than the exception
wow that is unbelievable you could do a
poll maybe or something
i i you know i heard in one of your one
of your videos you talked about this guy
investing in uh oh i don't want to
misquote what it was
let me see i think i wrote it down verge
or
right he he he verge like 50x
after you talked about it again i can't
say how crazy
that was not on me def not exclusively
on me i think i made
one of the first two verge videos out
there but but
there are there are hundreds of videos
okay sure sure fair enough
but you made a video and then basically
months later this guy got in
and lost all his money and he sent you
an email about it
and uh yeah i don't know how you would
deal with this
i mean it was it was literally a death
threat that like you lost me on
all my money right yeah and you can
i i agree with you that like should you
be
totally responsible no is there s
i don't know i'm not an ethicist or
whatever
but it can't feel good to hear that you
know i
pumped some stock i said it was good and
you can make all the qualifications you
want
about a tip a recommendation whatever
but at the end of the day
you know that was your video he acted on
it because of your video
and then like materially he's hurt even
though it's a stupid decision on his
part
right but i think i think that's a more
general problem right because i i think
it was more than a few months i think it
was maybe
six months or maybe even a year yeah
it's an education problem
for for him as well about like how to
you know manage your money how to think
about crypto
sure you said you said in one of your
videos that
self-help is useless or a lot of
self-help is useless let's qualify
and it's the blind leading the blind
what do you mean by that
i mean i'm i mean this is so basic but
the
the good old socrates quote that all i
know is
that i know nothing but i mean and of
course it shouldn't be taken literally
but it's just this whole
understanding that
people who who are very confident and
who think they have everything figured
out
generally i mean it's back to the
dunning-kruger effect essentially is
what i'm describing right now that
people who know less is more inclined to
believe they know everything there is to
know about a subject matter and people
who
actually know a lot about a subject
matter or more experts if you will
are more prone to realizing that
other a lot of holes in my knowledge
about this topic right
so so from the outside it seems that the
expert is less knowledgeable
than the fool and that creates this
mechanism of
the blind leading the blind and
sometimes they end up in a good place
to be fair but that's just sheer luck
luckily my followers don't have to worry
about that because i truly do know
everything yeah you're blessed in that
sense
nobody but there's some truth to that
right no there's no truth that
no no all i know is that i know nothing
guys
i'm basically socrates at this point
one thing that i thought was funny and i
wanted to tell you that i reacted
i i could have called it like had we
been had we been friends at the time
i could have told you people's answer to
this question
because in your quitting crypto video
you said quote
here it is you were talking about how
like you were wanting to talk about
philosophy and
all these things and i i wrote down what
you said because i thought it was
so funny you said this because i think i
know the answer
you you told your subscriber sort of as
a rhetorical question
would you rather learn some important
stuff that ultimately sheds light
on not just yourself but all humans or
listen to some dude reading you crypto
news with little to no
rev relevance in your life let me
rephrase it
would you rather join the ranks of the
top minds in the world
and ultimately be able to implement this
knowledge into your life
joining the few percent of the global
population
who even has this knowledge or just
listen to some crypto news and try to
make some money
you said that because to you it was so
obvious that everyone would say oh yeah
yeah of course i just want to know the
deep
secrets of the world and i want to
understand myself yeah
metacognition is so interesting and i
want to learn epistemology
and i could have told you
having been on youtube long enough what
your audience's
actual answer to the question is and it
is they want to hear some dude read them
crypto
and tell them the easy answer and they
don't want to hear about how
it's complicated and they don't want to
hear about how it's nuanced and they
don't want to hear any of that
instead they want to know what the stock
tip or coin tip
is and that's it uh so i thought it was
hilarious that you said that because i
really i thought to myself oh
man this is i mean einstein is always 20
20 right i said
this it's a lesson in the making
about how um just how people think
or don't think uh yeah yeah
anyway absolutely anyway so
hi guys uh you heard it here i think
your story is
fascinating ask her i think you're
fascinating
you're a great person people should go
follow you at ask ask her
on youtube um thank you so much for
taking the time
and yeah you too stephen taking time out
of your day appreciate you coming on the
show
any last words for people sign us off
here
think about why you believe what you
believe
that goes for micro decisions should i
invest in this
should i go this way or that way
should i try something new just just
think about why you believe
what you believe that's really don't
follow the hype
or do follow the hype but know that
that's what you're doing
if you're doing it sure thanks
thanks steven appreciate it
you